le colloque sur les 70 ans de la
départementalisation s'est ouvert ce
matin dans l'hémicycle du conseil
départemental mieux comprendre les
enjeux soixante dix ans après la loi de
1946 et différents partenaires ont posé
les axes de ce développement d'après la
période coloniale
un développement qui a permis de
construire une égalité entre le
territoire français et la réunion alors
regardez l'histoire des 70 dernières
années permet de voir d'où l'on part à
la réunion et quels ont été les progrès
accomplis
même s'il reste encore un rattrapage à
effectuer le chiffre que je trouve le
plus marquant c'est l'espérance de vie
au moment de la départementalisation
elle est à peu près de 50 ans et elle va
gagner 30 ans en 70 ans et donc à en 46
on avait dix sept années d'écart avec la
métropole
en termes d'espérance de vie aujourd'hui
on a moins de deux ans donc le
rattrapage n'est pas terminé mais c'est
un chiffre marquant le deuxième c'est
peut-être les logements à les logements
des réunionnais à l'époque ce sont
surtout des case en tôle sans eau et
sans électricité même 20 ans après la
départementalisation
on a seulement deux logements sur 10 qui
sont en dur et trois logements sur 10 kg
ont accès à l'eau et l'électricité
aujourd'hui donc plus de neuf logements
sur 10 sont en dur et quasiment tous les
logements où l'eau et l'électricité donc
là le rattrapage a pu être fait dans le
département était nation avoir excellent
de la mise en deuil la
départementalisation
donc son rôle est fondamental elle a
réussi avec d'autres tout ce qui était
rattrapage social rattrapage humains
aussi réduit on a quand même là on a
quand même la compétence agricole mais
au-delà de cela
comme tous les autres aussi le
département doit pouvoir aujourd'hui
avec la région réunion est en symbiose
symbiose et elle peut paraître un peu
fort mais en tout cas être en
coordination la plus totale l'argent est
rare les projets de mérite d'être
concertée des défendent un a besoin de
trouver ici et le département à côté des
mairies côté de la région pour qu'une
parole réunionnaise puisse s'exprimer
soit des moyens internes allons faire
jeux comme zelda président solidarité
nationale est méritée solidarité locale
à me faire jouer
un projet réunionnais qui font nettement
à responsabilité réunionnaise autrement
dit
nou lé kapab nous réunionnais de 20
projets pas même pour limiter tout nous
mêmes en pleine négociation avec
l'europe avec la france métropolitaine
dont plus tard grand témoin de ce
colloque paul vergès albert ramassamy et
jean paul virapoullé figure politique
locale qui se sont battus pour cette
départementalisation pour avoir leur
légalité charles il a fallu attendre 50
ans attention
et pour l'obtenir il a fabriqué les waro
et moi même pas nous étions débuté
nous avons plus de demandes démissionner
à l'assemblée nationale en disant nous
ne resterons plus dans cette assemblée
temps pour nous
c'est là qu'on a eues mais 50 ans après
c'est très simple c'est un désolé pour
vous amuser dans ces maniaques du jour
c'était interdit
il ya quelques dizaines d'années qui va
imposer c'est nous au temps des colonies
je prenais mon instituteur lui et vous
voyez comme cooper kanu que le créateur
dans les champs où j'habitais chambre et
puis la départementalisation a fait de
nous des professeurs du proviseur nous
apporter ce qui était nécessaire à
l'évolution indispensable à notre
transformation
c'est à dire l'apport de l'éducation
aujourd'hui la départementalisation est
un support pour faire de la réunion un
exemple dans le sang indien porte
maritime de l'europe porte de liaisons
aériennes développer le numérique
développer l'agro alimentaire développer
le tourisme
il faut continuer et j'ai dit aux
réunionnais nous avons la chance d'avoir
deux cartes d'un objet l'europe et la
france avec ses deux atouts majeurs
allons bosser allons transpirer allons
pas plein à nous allons construire
l'avenir
l'avenir c'est l'éducation la formation
et l'équipement du pays
l'ouverture au monde la rentrée dans la
mondialisation et nous pouvons le faire
parce que nous sommes des patrons
français et régions ultra périphériques
de l'europe gouvernance développement
humain économie emploi et surtout
quelles perspectives pour demain le
colloque des 70 ans ouvre des champs à
explorer mais surtout des solutions à
trouver pour que la réunion inscrive son
développement humain et économique et un
son territoire océan indien dans la
france dans l'europe mais également dans
le monde